the jurgen experience doesn't nicotine
as well nicotine has some sort of a
nootropic
prof uh benefit to it not not
encouraging people to smoke but you know
you could take it in various forms
particularly gum
i know people take it in gum just for
the uh
nootropic benefit of it yeah i'm not
encouraging people to take anything but
there's a very
very famous uh nobel prize winning
neuroscientist
who uh i went to his office to visit him
in new york and he
chewed seven pieces of nicorette during
that half hour meeting and i was like
what is going on here and he said
well first of all it increases
plasticity and second of all
he has the belief and this is not a
clinical study but he thinks that it can
also hold off
certain forms of parkinson's and
alzheimer's didn't bertrand wrestled
wasn't he like a
famous smoker like wouldn't even i don't
know i think i think he wouldn't even
go on a plane unless there was a smoking
section because he couldn't imagine not
having his pipe
for a certain amount of time well
creatives you know when i think when
smoking became less in vogue i think
creatives really suffered because
it's very clear that so nicorette is
nicotine and
the acetylcholine binds to the nicotinic
receptor
so when you take nicotine in cigarette
form or in nicarate form you're actually
increasing the release of acetyl with
the action of acetylcholine in the brain
yeah i don't smoke cigarettes but i have
and
the only time i have is before shows
because i have friends that are
comedians
that would smoke and i'd be like give me
one of them things let me see what's
going on
and i smoked i was like whoa dude you
get high off these things this is crazy
particularly if you don't smoke
cigarettes you get this really weird
high
well your receptors have never seen that
level of nicotine before and then right
they like that it's exciting
yeah yeah and so for those moments you
know your
your acetylcholine is like a spotlight
it brings your vision literally into
this more kind of portrait mode where
you can see
more like a narrow window of what's
going on
there are behavioral ways to access this
too before a fight you know somebody's
really ramped up their world is not
they're not seeing everything they're
probably i've never done the walk of
course but probably walking out to the
octagon they're not seeing all the
the color of the hat or the woman in the
corner you know they're not relaxed
they're hyped up
but that's a trigger for plasticity
because the brain needs some way to cue
this plasticity prostitute let itself
know because it's a self-learning
organ let itself know that something's
really different that's adrenaline
something's changed then there's focus
what's changed so
in the jiu jitsu example you gave
earlier it's the ability to focus on
what the sequence is what happens when
and okay i did that correctly or i
didn't do that correctly but that's
duration path and outcome again
and having acetylcholine and
noradrenaline up
that sets the plasticity trigger however
that doesn't guarantee that those
synapses are going to change it does not
mean that you're necessarily going to
learn
i don't know what guarantees that that
process will be converted
into literally the change in the
connections between neurons sometimes
new neurons but mostly the change in the
strength of the connection so that
eventually you don't have to do duration
path outcome you can just be reflexive
about it
is states of deep sleep and any state
where you're not doing
duration path outcome so we know from
two recent studies some of this was done
by my lab but by other labs as well in
humans
which i think is important to
distinguish between mouse and human when
where we can
a lot of the changes in these brain
structures occurs
after learning during deep sleep in
particular slow wave sleep
but it also occurs during periods of
naps and shallow sleep or even just
periods where people deliberately
decompress where they're not
focusing on any one thing in particular
so
if we were going to kind of
operationalize this process it would be
focus intensely have an intense period
of urgency
and then access the deepest rest you can
where you're not thinking about anything
where space and time becomes very fluid
so stress in that case post
exercise or learning session would
actually
hinder your ability to grow and get
better absolutely
and elite performers like elite military
elite athletes i'm sure you're familiar
with this
they understand that the ability to
toggle back and forth between these high
alert high attentional states
and deep rest is not just the key to
performing what you can already
what you can already do it's also the
ability to get better over time
[Applause]